ça le gars
oui allô
tu vas voir allô
deuxième fois sans aucun problème et ben
ça marche tu veux leur dire un truc
j'adore les c'est doux
en même temps c'est bien parce que il a
besoin de productivité Cédric allez on
fait ça je vous en avais parlé il y a
quelques mois mais pour ceux qui ne
savent pas eau douce est un logiciel de
gestion d'entreprise avec un éventail
d'applications pour simplifier la
gestion quotidienne des entreprises
alors ils ont des applications comme un
CRM une comptabilité une facturation
autrement dit au tout c'est une solution
modulable qui vous permet une simplicité
de gestion et une réduction des prises
de tête en fonction de vos besoins et
sans rien oublier et audou propose un
business model original vous avez la
gratuité à vie de la solution si vous
utilisez une seule des applications et
la solution devient payante à partir de
la deuxième application c'est pas mal ça
permet de tester de découvrir mais
également la création de site web ou de
boutiques en ligne d'ailleurs si ça peut
vous intéresser sachez que en plus de
votre site gratuit l'hébergement et le
support sont inclus de manière illimitée
en plus de votre nom de domaine
personnalisé qui est gratuit pendant un
an en plus de ça la plateforme du site
web est très rapide à configurer après
si vous le souhaitez vous pouvez être
guidé par un configurateur de site et
puis surtout il y a la simplicité
d'utilisation avec un système très
simple de drague and drop qui donne une
vraie fluidité dans le travail en gros
il y a besoin d'aucune connaissance
technique pour réaliser son site
Internet en quelques minutes donc si
vous voulez en savoir plus sur la
création de site web avec Audoux et sur
tous les autres services qui proposent
je vous mets un lien dans la description
salut aujourd'hui je vais vous donner
une astuce de mentaliste pour apprendre
un maximum d'informations sur un sujet
donné quand vous avez seulement deux ou
trois jours pour le faire alors pourquoi
je fais cette vidéo parce que déjà je
sais que vous en avez besoin vous avez
vu le titre vous avez cliqué vous êtes
17 années j'ai besoin de ça et ensuite
parce que il y a quelques semaines j'ai
partagé sur Instagram le fait que
j'étais en train de passer mon permis
bateau mon permis côtier avec Doc seven
on a passé ensemble et qu'on avait fait
ça en deux jours parce qu'on s'y était
pas pris à l'avance dans les stories
j'ai expliqué que j'avais une petite
méthode pour apprendre vite ce genre de
truc et j'ai reçu à peu près ça comme
pile de commentaires me disant si tu
pouvais nous dire comment tu faisais
peut-être ça nous intéresserait alors
c'est parti
[Musique]
un des meilleurs systèmes pour apprendre
c'est la répétition espacée ou quelque
chose de modifier comme ma mémorable par
exemple vous allez pouvoir
identifier là où il faut vous concentrer
plus et surtout ne pas perdre de temps
sur ce que vous connaissez déjà et ça en
général on le fait avec avec des
flashcards comme celle-ci ça c'est des
flashcards qui viennent de la boutique
brainstorm je vous mettrai ça le lien
dans la description bon ça c'est
extrêmement efficace quand vous avez du
temps par exemple pour mémoriser des
choses sur une année parce que vous avez
un diplôme à la fin de l'année ou dans
la vie personnelle sur une passion ou
dans la vie professionnelle parce que
vous devez avoir une bonne connaissance
d'un sujet alors j'ai un petit système à
la olicard on pourra appeler ça le
système à l'arrache oly car c'est pas
facile de faire un jeu de mots là et de
vous faire voir directement comment j'ai
fait pour le permis côtier la première
phase ça consiste à lire l'intégralité
de tout ce que vous allez devoir
apprendre le lire trois fois ça c'est
plutôt bien si vous n'avez pas le temps
que vous lisez qu'une fois mais faut le
lire au moins une seule fois en entier
donc moi j'avais tous livres à apprendre
par cœur on va passer tant de là-dessus
le but c'est de la compréhension de la
trace mnésique dans le cerveau la trace
amnésique c'est les premiers ponts en
fait de synapse entre les neurones qui
commencent déjà à retenir des choses à
votre insu la deuxième phase elle
consiste à identifier des choses qui
vont être importantes pour vous
l'information principale par exemple de
cette page c'est ça faut que j'y fasse
attention et ça qui est relié à ça tout
le reste en vrai c'était pour ma
première compréhension de lecture mais
je sais que je n'ai pas l'apprendre par
cœur donc j'identifie sur le sur la page
toutes les petites choses qui sont
importantes et puis je commence à faire
des schémas il faut il va falloir faire
le deuil de tenir vos livres propres il
faut commencer à gribouiller parce qu'en
plus c'est important parce que ça fait
travailler la mémoire corporelle donc la
mémoire procédurale et aussi les
sensations kinesthésiques et vous pouvez
aussi faire ça voix haute comme ça vous
cumulez la mémoire visuelle la mémoire
auditive la mémoire kinesthésique donc
trois lectures comme ça à blanc une
quatrième lecture ou vous commencez à
noter et à identifier tout ce qui va
falloir apprendre entre temps vous
commencez à acheter le matériel dont
vous allez avoir besoin les conseils de
fabou je vous recommande beaucoup de
feutres de plein de couleurs différentes
et leur particulièrement ce style de
feutre pas forcément cette marque
celui-ci je vous mettra aussi en lien
dans la description mais n'importe quoi
fera l'affaire ce sont des doubles mines
ou côté vous avez un feutre et de
l'autre côté une pointe fine là pour
écrire normalement parce que le cognitif
il aime bien les couleurs et l'aime bien
les trucs surligner il aime bien les
petits dessins avec ça vous couvrez tout
et enfin et c'est tout il y a pas besoin
de trop de matériel vous vous procurez
des flashcards alors ça peut être des
flashcards comme celle de brainstorm que
je vous faisais voir tout à l'heure donc
là on est on est sur un gros format ça
peut être aussi des choses plus légères
la moitié j'ai utilisé ça c'est
extrêmement bien à une seule condition
que effectivement vous n'ayez pas besoin
de stocker après parce que dans le temps
je pense pas que ça tienne bien bien la
route donc c'est c'est très bien pour du
temporaire en fait si vous voulez garder
dans le temps prenez quelque chose de
plus costaud comme ça mais tout comme le
système Lettner n'est pas possible et ça
envahit revenir c'est pas possible non
plus d'apprendre ça avec le vrai système
des flashcards une flashcard ça
fonctionne comme ça ces deux
informations qui vont être séparées si
je prends la flash card de la box
culture générale il y a marqué Egypte
Afrique il faut que je me rappelle du
nom de la capitale c'est le Caire et si
je retourne c'est bien le Caire donc ça
veut dire que si je tombe sur la carte
le Caire il faudrait que je trouve que
c'est E que ça se trouve en Afrique vous
vous avez trop d'informations à retenir
si ça va pas être possible de faire une
flashcard par double information mais en
même temps si vous faites une fiche de
révision ça va pas vous être utile aussi
non plus pour apprendre ça rapidement
donc vous allez faire un mix des deux en
utilisant de la couleur et surtout de la
synthèse d'information les fiches de
révision elles sont faites pour
apprendre quelque chose vos
intermédiaires entre flashcard et fils
de révision elles vont être pour
vérifier que vous connaissez
l'information et réviser quelque chose
pas pour l'apprendre donc ça a pas
besoin d'être un résumé de quelque chose
je vous prends un exemple d'une petite
feuille efficace là d'un côté j'ai
marqué la marée avec pourquoi la marée
contrairement à une flashcard je vais
pas réviser d'un coup de ce côté pour
retenir de l'autre côté et d'un coup ce
côté pour retenir de l'autre côté je
tomberai toujours sur celui-ci j'ai
utilisé une typologie de couleur une
catégorie toutes mes cartes qui
concernent la marée sont avec cette
couleur là comme ça ça s'incrément dans
une population de neurones de ma tête de
l'autre côté j'ai fait un tout petit
schéma très rapide avec la terre avec
deux on va dire gonflements de chaque
côté et la lune de ce côté-là et des
petits signaux devant la Lune comme ça
ça me rappelle visuellement j'ai ce
dessin maintenant quand en tête une fois
que je l'ai créé ça me rappelle que la
Lune a la tire l'eau avec son attraction
donc ça fait gonfler une marée haute du
côté de la lune et que comme la terre
elle tourne sur elle-même ça veut dire
que de l'autre côté il y a cette même
marée haute et je prends des dur que des
œufs deux autres côtés forcément il y a
marée basse et même ce dessin là même si
je l'ai pas marqué ça commence déjà à me
rappeler que du coup si la Lune est
alignée du même côté que le soleil alors
ça va faire une énorme marée parce qu'il
y aura beaucoup d'attraction au
contraire si le soleil de l'autre côté
de la planète alors ça va contrarier
l'attraction linéaire et du coup on aura
une marée haute moins haute et après
j'ai écrit en rouge pour bien me
rappeler de ça et pour bien de
l'identifier s'il y a de plaines et deux
basses en environ 24 heures cette phrase
là encore une fois vous avez vu elle
veut rien dire si quelqu'un prenait mes
fiches il comprendrait pas de quoi je
parle elle me parle à moi parce que je
les ai faites et c'est juste pour me
rappeler qu'il y a de pleine mer et deux
basses mer de marée haute de marée basse
en environ 24 heures parce que c'est
c'est pas tout à fait 24 heures mais
j'ai juste besoin de me rappeler de et
ça clairement rien que cette petite
feuille elle résume une page une page et
demie voire deux pages de ce bouquin là
mais vous l'avez compris les dessins
sont vos amis les organisations sans vos
amis et puis n'hésitez pas à mettre
plusieurs informations par carte là
c'est important ça sur une flashcard les
trois types de roches qu'on trouve sur
une carte marine le à fleur d'eau
couvrable et découvrable ou toujours
submergé ça m'aurait pris trois
flashcards à la base mais là on a pas le
temps parce que c'est en deux ou trois
jours qu'on doit réviser ça c'est la fin
de la première étape il est évident que
toute cette étape là suivant ce que vous
avez à prendre ça va vous prendre une
longue demi-journée c'est-à-dire 5
heures par exemple ou une bonne journée
entière même si vous avez que deux jours
passés par là vous faites pas ça pour
rien ça commence à apprendre ça prend du
temps mais c'est ça vaut mieux que de
réaliser au pif vraiment vous vous
marquez des meilleurs skills des
meilleurs points avec ça fin de journée
fin de cette première étape vous faites
votre propre système vous rassemblez
toutes les cartes vous les mélangez
entre elles vous passez un coup d’œil
sur chacune des cartes et vous commencez
déjà à éliminer que vous êtes sûr de
savoir pour toujours vous pouvez aussi
faire comme moi c'est à dire d'un côté
vous faire un système avec les cartes
qui a vraiment réalisé et les autres
plutôt que de les jeter vous voulez
mettez sur un autre système sur le côté
et comme ça peut-être juste avant
l'examen ou au moment où vous aurez
besoin de cette connaissance vous
pourrez juste pour vous rassurer le
faire une dernière fois mais sur les
deux trois jours de révision vous
repasserez pas dessus ensuite c'est le
moment de l'apprentissage et ben c'est
pas une fois par jour c'est autant de
fois que vous pouvez dès que vous pouvez
mais vous avez toujours ça dans la poche
ou vos flashcards avec vous dans votre
sac et vous le faites à chaque fois que
vous pouvez alors si vous voulez mettre
toutes les chances de votre côté vous le
faites debout vous le faites en marchant
ça aussi j'aime les cerveau ça fait
travailler la mémoire procédurale vous
faites à voix haute en faisant des
gestes par exemple la marée vous avez vu
directement j'ai fait alors il y a la
terre de chaque côté en même temps c'est
des gestes que je faisais au moment où
je lisais mes propres fiches et mes
propres cartes vous faites travailler
tous les types de mémoire et essayez
même de le faire ailleurs de là où vous
apprenez habituellement dans un café
debout dans la rue dans votre cuisine
changer les endroits où vous apprenez
parce que là aussi ça va faire marcher
le interne et donc vous rajoutez encore
des possibilités d'apprendre bien et
vite donc là forcément pour apprendre
vous lisez bien les deux côtés ensuite
vous commencez à passer à la phase de
l'autotest vous ouvrez et vous partez de
la première feuille à la dernière
feuille et là moi je lis navire en route
avec R1 sans R et bien dans ma tête et à
voix haute j'essaie de me rappeler tout
ce que ça veut dire et d'en dire plus
même que ce que j'ai marqué donc en
route ça veut dire que le navire a pas
d'attache il a pas l'encre il a pas
d'Amar etc avec R c'est-à-dire qu'il est
propulsé il avance par rapport à l'eau
sans air ça veut dire qu'il glisse sur
son air donc en gros il est à la dérive
et vous vérifiez tout de suite après le
premier plus d'attache donc c'est bien
tout ce que j'ai dit propulser c'est
bien ce que j'ai dit aussi dérive c'est
bien ce que j'ai dit aussi donc vous
voyez encore une fois c'était
synthétique mais forcément comme je me
suis créé des populations neurones pour
un savoir et bien j'ai tendance à
dérouler et je me force à en faire
remonter le plus possible donc vous
faites ça vous vous auto testez autant
de fois que vous pouvez et sur cette
auto-stest c'est là où peut-être vous
allez dire certaines fiches vous la
passer dans le deuxième système parce
que vraiment à son maîtriser et celle
que vous j'avais pas assez maîtriser
c'est pas la peine de les mettre
ailleurs je vous rappelle que vous avez
que deux trois jours pour réviser il n'y
a pas le temps de prendre le temps tout
ça pour moi c'est vraiment les étapes du
premier jour ou un jour et demi maximum
après si vous avez l'occasion le mieux
c'est de continuer les autocontrôle
certes mais de se faire contrôler par
quelqu'un évidemment vous ferez des
erreurs vous prononcerez pas les mots
exacts etc mais ça vous mettra une forme
de pression et qui est intéressante
parce que cette émotion comme ça elle va
aussi vous faire ancrer les choses
c'est-à-dire que quand vous allez faire
une erreur vis-à-vis de quelqu'un elle
va plus vous marquer cette erreur que si
vous le faisiez tout seul parce que
c'est un souvenir épisodique ça inclut
la personne et après c'est comme ça
jusqu'au bout c'est pas si compliqué
c'est très inspiré donc de la mémory box
du système letter du principe des
flashcards et des fiches de révision et
ça prend en compte tout ce que je
connais moi sur le cerveau pour me faire
ce petit système là parenthèse autopromo
ça fait pas de mal mémoire vous allez
pouvoir c'est mon dernier livre avec
toutes mes astuces de mémoire il y a pas
celle-ci dedans parce que j'ai fait
plutôt des choses sur sur Youtube pas
trop sur l'urgence
mais parfois on a besoin quand même
d'apprendre en urgence donc je m'étais
dit que faire cette vidéo ça pourrait
vous intéresser le lien vers le bouquin
en description j'espère que ça vous sera
utile c'est pas la meilleure manière
d'apprendre encore une fois c'est un
système que j'ai créé le vous êtes dit
comment le à l'arrache au Lyca c'est un
système que j'ai créé pour combler mes
propres besoins d'urgence à moi et je
sais bien que parfois on n'a pas les
situations idéales et que des fois on
doit apprendre beaucoup de choses très
rapidement au moins vous serez comment
faire si vous vous y tenez vraiment bien
vous aurez pas de problème mais vraiment
mais il faut s'y tenir après faut s'auto
contrôler en permanence sur les deux
trois jours et pour ceux qui se
demandent si ça a marché là pour moi
pour le permis côtier oui j'ai eu 39
bonnes réponses sur 40 et doc seven qui
passait avec moi et à qui je reversais
mes trucs mes astuces mes dessins mes
machins ah oui c'est 39 sur 40 aussi et
franchement pour lui comme pour moi
notre seule erreur qui est pas la même
évidemment c'est clairement une erreur
d'inatorsion en lisant mal l'énoncé
merci encore à Odou de voir sponsorisé
cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à découvrir
leurs services le lien est dans la
description allô
est-ce que vous êtes déjà entendu parler
de mon compte Instagram voilà parce que
j'ai à peu près 20 000 abonnés c'est une
certaine audience et je me disais
peut-être trop vous et moi on pourrait
tu vois allez OK et doux non c'est toi
qui raccroche au nous non c'est allez
mais c'est toi et c'est qui qui moi je
m'appelle Fabien olicard je suis
toujours mentaliste je suis toujours sur
Youtube la preuve en est n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner liker cette vidéo à la
partager à l'enregistrer aussi pourquoi
pas dans vos favoris pour retrouver
quand vous aurez besoin de ça prenez
soin de vous à très bientôt Ciao